tf à 20 heures avec jean claude bourret
valéry giscard d'estaing demain en
arabie saoudite le plus grand réservoir
de pétrole du monde
les municipales à paris les hypothèses
après la candidature de jacques chirac
l'épave du bollène colmatage enfin
terminée la mode printemps-été 77 des
robes plissées détail marquer une ligne
classique
madame mademoiselle monsieur bonsoir ils
ont fait plus de 100 fois le tour de la
terre en cinq cents vols ils ce sont les
concordes le 21 janvier de l'année
dernière à 12h40 précise le concorde
d'air france et celui de la british
airways décollé à la même seconde tout
cela vous l'avez vécu en direct grâce
aux caméras de tf1
le concorde d'air france avait à son
bord une seule équipe de télévision
celle de notre cher maintenant après un
an d'exploitation
c'est l'heure du bilan côté rentabilité
c'est le déficit 220 millions de francs
mais concorde ne veulent pas sur son
réseau définitif
il n'a effectué que cinq cents liaison
sur des itinéraires qui sont les débuts
d'un grand réseau et on attend notamment
le 10 février prochain avec impatience
la décision des autorités américaines
pour une liaison paris new york près de
trente mille passagers ont été
transportés soit un taux de remplissage
de 61 % des avions en corde
il est évident que l'avenir du
supersonique franco-britannique passe
d'abord par les autorisations
d'atterrissage qui lui sont nécessaires
pour se poser aussi bien à new york qu'à
tokyo
la british airways dispose maintenant de
trois concorde air france également
mais la compagnie française recevra un
quatrième concorde en avril
présidentielle le président giscard à un
panier de deux ministres monsieur guérin
place aux enchères le chien entre
heureuse pour l'extérieur
le président des stars à demain dans un
lit en laine et qu'on est conique grâce
autres dollars en r et saoudiens ans et
une industrialisation touzet zine ben
ali sous 10 jan 2010
c'est de boucler sa liste assez bien
jean les esprits culte et ou du
développement de l'arabisme première
bouletterie défense elle coûte 19 pts
imite en arabe c'est le cri mais
également pour t'expliquer on se la
prend l'eau dans la soupe de farine et
se paie autres à la radio dj mc fois
dont cherche de l'eau que l'on pose un
tout c'est lui d'autres arabie saoudite
et sa gloire plus bas c'est tolérance et
pour la majeure part qu'en territoire à
l'équipe 2 des rails alors avis prend
loup elle se tenait mer rouge au sud et
gold rabou quercy morts c'est digne de
diniz escient derrière par les
américains feraient de la prée 20
millions d'euros par jour les japonais
ont construit votre deux fois importante
à coude autre signe par axis instruction
set au couvert et ses grains pétrole que
le service soit latrille et bien
d'augmenter solution que depuis 2 25% à
thiviers londres fourche et pas chers
que les produits clés le principal pour
très peu pétrole déterminante de rastan
véritable science des gens après un
cinquième titre mondial sans dire
l'europe et l'asie réfugiés fiscaux de
brink's ont fait 7000 s'organise une vie
occidental cours était rihanna qui
connaît des embouteillages qui n'ont
rien à envier ceux de londres à nuire
partout dans le pays on construit tout d
europe où les routes de tenue et reprend
viseur le mérite chantier grâce
notamment aux importations de manoeuvre
était relégué européennes étaient
initiés tout au contraire de simple il
doit venir des tristan de du sud ou de
colomb laisse ben métier de riz les
collègues viennent et qui fait s'emporte
tomber sur réservé lance failli à la
tradition s'illustre ici pas des
mannequins femmes de sortir des coups tu
m'envoies l'axé un genou sans faire
d'économie aussi des bruits de profiter
de la technologie ou venant tard
parles trop si tu mets un port rs grâce
à l'argent et en grande keep pour être
des chars et les belles d'attendre peut
être moins de larges port de djeddah ou
de celui là m'a pourri du temps il en
plus il ya des deux packs djeddah
déchets carte sim à l'enclos de moyens
traditionnels son cliché l'aimions hull
qui corps - greater peas est un tout
petit enclos et c'est oui bien passé de
ces pays se prévalent à j aime bien
disposés aux people élite et vetra
landes aura 102 marc scheer alors il
faut aménager le dr ici à la grâce à des
pertes est un creuset à 50 mètres au
frère ou soit de degré perriguey 20
mille hectares et si con c'est l'envié
les premières pole terre de l'arabie la
liste mais elle ça ne leur manque qu'un
douzième du p panda dans l'énergie
pétrole arabe filiales sur m l'exploit
tient de l'os sinon vie traditionnelle
liste avec le comedd outre tsonga no 10
et la part outre on n'est pas des frères
k dans le corps ces dégâts assurés
français contre la mesure de politique
dans les entreprises c'est seul que
révèle un sondage clio juil votre
confrère le nouvelle miss plein dixième
giscard d'estaing ex p à nouveau son
opposition à toute politisation rire
elle rester un lieu d'un vice président
de la république ça ference de presse
voici autant d'acquis manque majorité
des français pensent surpoids comme le
présent jusqu'à cet éclair de la lune à
dali deux sont des iphone
la politisation d'entreprise et plus
encore d'agitation meeting et ses heures
possibilité la majorité des français et
divise profondément y compris les hommes
et et dans la gauche pourtant favorable
sur ce refus les pubs les marques donc
des points en éclats en revanche les
france paul qui me fait penser à
majorité que les bons et proclamant de
ne traduisent pas en fait de politiques
et une pipe mot à 10 mais que c'est faux
c'est là un arc pour la gauche gagne de
roche à la police comme un gout flash
politique la défense du smi non par le
patronat que voit fox entreprises lesage
ifop nouvel économiste
entre ainsi que la moyenne d'avant
saison 1 personnellement pour est un
saint à différents
les puces style le chef de l'état porte
sur la moitié des salariés du corps ce
cadre loyer ce sur les tares de la
mériter les prises et les ouvriers de la
moitié en colocation du temps
l'entreprise
un type ou
on le trouve aegon potier pour mes gros
tu vois c'est quand même un bon ce n'est
pas apte rend la famille politique à
l'usiné même avec des syndicats
politisés buts 6 sur une vieille mais
france 2 les trois r
la politique ça est ce trop les sons des
fesses pour droite et surtout c'est
qu'il ne faudrait pas se mêler qui
communiste de plus afin de filmer ses
prises contre eux plus de social et 200
tr que poussière à bien cette résidence
tout est parti de montrant qu'elle me
décrit dans le rang lui n'a pas vendangé
par pm du style à face il y travaille à
la petite seconde il passe en france
pour relancer par le ps que con de
patronne en mineur des roches munissent
pour proposer des solistes ont entre
neuf et renforcer leur position leur
sein l'acteur brière a fait bon quérir à
des voix point clé dans l'économie
le pca d'ellory d'action petit sous
l'indicatif ses gérants content que la
augmente plus les échelles influence
bharti simple lieu traces des classes
l'entreprise est en fait entre vital de
ce thème duction emploie 600 kits fois
dans un sens us tic en compte tant
religieuses il est en tout cas france et
il est réglé leur leader gic hurle un de
leurs gammes à la candidature aux prises
deux rakas la mairie de paris à protège
vendre une réaction mais il en est un
autre
tout proche de faire le poids peut
essayer de maple verts avaient ce tour
on peut lire patrie oui l hygiène un peu
folle il tenait ce fait un poil est donc
aux cours de se faire entre elle et je
présente les nouveaux prêtres pour
l'ajouter cural me dire si tu mets
orgueil tactique et 8 et un programme
est maintenant les centres et les
radicaux approuvent
j'ai quand même si lui demander aux durs
et marc ont un moment à 11 iations cld
et de l'accord assure général à
l'intention des représentats par
initiative et génère interprète à ce
qu'on a comme un duo m la majorité est
là président la république
même si jacques peas qu'ils y défient
allocution torna le sel d'un côté
maintient sa conduire ont donc dire ce
soir qu'il y ait rien à duhamel appétits
charnels raw même rast avec l'appui
vernement il prône istres qui éviterait
en sa faveur et des petits républicain
cependant très radicaux jacques survie
le croit produire et air qu'il préside
dans l'opposition les risques et pas
très claires donc les disciples dire
aujourd'hui communiste et se disent tu
tires on en sent la bataille tous les
noms les plus tôt alors des surfeurs se
présente la situation constatée le
tableau quoi et n'évoque malaisie
peut-être première thèse jacques chaque
écart de prix il prend en doute une
dimension x nanterre
mais ces victoires actes et condamnant
engouement appuyé par le premier
ministre et la cambre expire ce sa
demande le moins
dans ils en rajoutent des cas les
problèmes deuxième hypothèse c'est
miller ne gagne la bataille paris
l'ancien premier ministre vaincu période
beaucoup plus de se confier la dynamique
du père ancien coup et là où le paysage
de troisième place de la victoire de
l'opposition en croit les chiffres les
derniers ce sont elles et peut pas mais
c'est actuellement ex pas que six feet 2
division de la maj presse deux points la
dérogation or comment un genre
littéraire et culturel amauri serait en
ligne street chaque pourra-t-elle
retrait après les tunisiens ont qu à
paris et une semaine serena pleinement
le genre de resto risque-t-il quand on
était hier raymond barre souffrir des
lions de majorer séné les mordus de la
situation à un moment il ne faut oublier
la priorité numéro 1 du moment
rjc salle a alors germé au cours de
conférences est ce la prairie rouyn
reste du contrôle des prix et pour le
chômage aux deux été mis des coeurs on
peut penser la république au premier
ministre doit en tout cas cet accord de
redressement et 6 ans à l'heure actuelle
la principe réduction des frais dans le
lac qui oppose geyrac rpr ami joël de
rosnay depuis l'indépendance n'a mérité
il un point précis sur les deux pays
n'ont pas le même point de vue jacques
chirac ont extrait fait tous les
instances jurés étaient insultés pour
voir qu'à serez le mans 10 munich dettes
majorées type paris voici la pose de
monsieur michel d'ornay au monde de
piles ou glace il un compte à paris cet
après midi chaque question majorité
sortent pour béziers 110 da est venu ça
et pas avec des missiles dans toute
l'ile-de-france qui commençait bien que
ça qu'on a posés je lui dis ici un monde
se produit pourquoi une licence sur mon
nom et l'adulte et éclaire nationale
jury à plusieurs reprises une idée ont
pris plus de temps à se trouver dans les
rangs qualifié de l'unr sont au dessus
dit charles viet-nam l'abbé s'il sait si
dénoncer ce il adapté qu'elle semblait
que son ce nom on voulait voir dès
maintenant comment est venue la
candidate de monsieur jacques chirac ait
un procès il construit ni ses procédures
de paris nice et partenaires la majorité
il ses désirs tout seul sans pile
d'autres encore longtemps parlé
constation je trouve des propos un peu
ton du moyen et et ses prédictions refus
makdah du rct histoires des histoires
qui se passait quand est constitué de
climat politique nation
monsieur journaux je voudrais vous la
poser sous l'angle des paris les
parisiens pourraient tout on est
premiers interceptant les affaires alors
monsieur chirac lévisienne saurait une
fois de plus montrer l'exemple aux
loisirs il a dit cela on à sa
candidature et indiqué hier qu est le
seul pilote pour cette majorité ne
craignez pas parisiennes et parisiens ce
soit at il mangé par situation karouf
opposition de sa majorité ce qui va dans
des petites monsieur chahpour que dire
tu as on croit qu'elle a poursuivi ce
qu'ils sont qui avec via les barrages
irak n'est pas que pour lisser le texte
à une balle piquée il qu'il vit porter
un déficit champagne pour appeler kwapis
ou trois quarts des députés sont des
députés de l'abriter via les 73 voilà
public a obtenu 5% des voix
c'est pas le prix suivant en anglais
cette autorité il monsieur chirac
voulait sans apposition lancé un défi
l'opposition à paris qu'il fallait
c'était dans l'un des fiefs de
l'audition pour sa part exacte des
tenues par l'opposition dans diaries
c'est malheureusement la majorité qui
vous oppose à candas du rabbi monsieur
chirac après fact division regrettable
dans la jolie t il pas infi a joué son
hockey dans une ville une solution
semblait assurée cette division et ce
grâce et justin l'opposion deuxième
suivi grade déguerpir pma précisément
rythme et les déclins de mesures sur la
procédure guljé riante candidature le
candidat le mieux
monsieur yves buffet cette délégation à
terrain dans le journal rays
il est évident lors que le baril car les
trains et lui cette élection prendre une
dimension te réponde être autrement
alors entre dans la salle et dansions de
matic
il ya une nuance son pack lui vaudra la
mairie seulement très sérieuse il est
aux ossètes courant mais je croise m
engage à simplement oui dans l'anneau
pas remplie qu'il y a eu un accord de la
majorité sur ce nom on peut dire qu'ils
n'aient rien et le sait car j -pd au
moma question est débattue ce candidat
que les républicains pendant à
l'argument du noble chez le riche en
enseignements de norman savon
l émotion qu ils étaient capables enfin
décision assez marginaux lorsque
magnitski a proposé tout mais free met a
fourbi trash d'humanisme ont classé les
champs tester la supputation de l'arrêt
du on ne pouvait passer la précipitation
réjouit-elle dire que le premier
ministre
mal conseillés en mesure digne pieux
d'euros et il y a donc accord
fondamental dans la joie ya toujours eu
un des axes fondamentaux dans la
majorité sur la désignation sud à nous
diviser monsieur le marché imm edouard
que la candidature de monsieur jacques
est une nation spectre est innée à peser
l'opinion remis chargé des relations
club parlement cohade que la vie brial
est heureusement à l'homme orks pas rien
je vais de monsieur la plage aux rites
et demeure unie au premier effet du parc
ans à farcir que président des jeunes
gymnique bulls roland le stand par
arriver affirmé votre espoir unités de
la majorité dans le succès plan barre
fatah enfin le midi qu'une du paradigme
de série les radicaux les sites
totalement le plan b à meilleur coût 10
un thème de la bri et qu'on a la vida
tour de monsieur jaca pas au micro de
marche verte bruce bistrot de mercer
plana man comédie heures partie dicale
qu'il va s'ouvrir une sommité xu ici à
d'abord dit et les avancées le gong
reste un parcours plein temps et leur
talent bien sûr démarches pour matt
affaires de parieurs n'ont pas même
étudié
l'homme est effectif oubliée la position
de la tête radiale ce système défectueux
de l'avenir laclais le soutien et
l'activation que présent monsieur michel
battant le communiqué mme cloutier
exécutif d'eads regrette que des
sciences est née lors de la majorité
puissent mettre en danger toute l'action
que mène
d'élire le premier sont vraiment bas et
nous avons souhaité que tout va mieux
pour que cette liste qui ont des
relations et pour notre esprit comique
de la troisième chambre correctionnelle
de paris a ordonné ce semi liberté des
huit ouvriers le poulpe et après les il
s'est appuyé dans les mardis à merck
ethernet ou accents exemple du parisien
libéré avait des rêves du htc a les yeux
du livre et la police est intervenue et
a levé justice de papeete dont les
regarder cet après midi par les forces
de l'ordre a fait vite et l'incident
plusieurs milliers déduit vran manifesté
dans lagardère ou barde alliés il n'ya
pas résultats sans la médiation sera sec
30 mickson selon la cgc dispersé de cale
legria raisière par an donc normalement
d'un samedi l'écho diane bas ce n'est
pas elle a fait part d' ordre du sica du
livre qui compte uniquement la région
parisienne au moment où la presse vers
une crise et la glaciale en france
derrière paris
que dit madame synodale caire mais d'ici
à quarante je reparte pas l'ombre d'un
quotidien merckx ou l'affût d'une
publication mais elle part on va publier
haussier sur les grands cette barre mais
il n'est pas impossible dans ce cas nous
madame del duca site de relay repas très
lourde sous la forme qu'ils sentent
notre humanité d'epône la présentation
de la perf à être complètement rigide de
faire un journal plus vivre combat avec
de grandes quêtes ne ment sur la
question en vie des français les
nouvelles formules praslin dit paula
vient toujours notre confrère a publié
un numéro zéro titre cesser cela vient
du monde s'ouvre il fera un bref récit
de francs jamais février frédérice 3-6
6-1 syndicaux région parisienne décidé
avidement de ne pas prendre part à la
grève du premier hier le mot d'ordre de
pédéraste reste à la leçon semble un air
france fait graver 24 le 20 mai pour un
tour personnel
les syndicats demandent une ovation des
salaires médiation à des conditions à
vannes large des côtes france la lutte
contre les pollueurs ce petit monsieur
s'encastre délecter de la ville cet
après midi nouveau système de détention
if you were système combine la
surveillance partielle mer et terre 1 ha
long est équipé d'appareils fera rouge
calme qui traitent directement isimat un
avis en liaison avec lui tu as wihr
également équipé de terra pour des
pétroliers texte large à 38 il offre au
reste de l'île d'un bar san siro devant
9000 d'azur font toujours peser une
grave menace sur les côtes bretonnes
le pétrolier ben coulé en oeuvre
dernière les compagnies spécialisées par
sous marine pour pouvoir que lemay
brèche en dix jours zone
mêlant le trio de coupât brefs
reportages de noyer le sial sur l'az
claude le pen au pied duquel on enterre
pomper le fioul du poète un taux de
vatra modère le cuivre peut conserver
édition tous ici à la verticale d'après
ses hélices la terrasse et un système
maison de la savane de plomb est conçu
autour de 6 entre eux ou avec de tes
moyens quoi ton 80 maté brèche du
pétrole et surtout dans sa sphère le
temps ces boucles environ 30 millions de
pages pointard d'abord les contres et
beaucoup plus difficile que les
moucheurs pratiquement qu'une visibilité
à philippe elle ne dépasse 500 types
euskaltel partie 5 m eur sont seulement
et puis un chèque de togliatti veulent
mater coffrage de béton n'a pas résisté
à la tempête
alors on a fait des coups plus de béton
du gucci enduit de résine et pendant
provisoire de la sorte en exploits de
pompage dans la politique mise au point
mais en ce moment on est dans quel item
permettent pas de réalité qui est le vin
en attendant les soupes du bandeau de
m'échauffer rhmani d'expirer l'assurance
nous séparer l'eau sera suite dans une
simple projet pouvoirs institués en du
pétrole et plus société de rim vient dé
soumis aux ministres quand la passion du
lot certes pour le temps or il faut lui
en pris 4
mais combien c'est une table ou sur la
montre qui s'engage le collage des
deviendra-t-il n'est pas certes la
future puis à la france a déjà un
milliard cent millions de centimes et
strange aubrystes allemagne de l'est
était athlète qui lui a fait mention de
danse pendant la première période mais
ne versera aucune habilité de 600 simple
on le sentait
après les naufrages que jamais les
chemins tôt en vieillard artistes de
marée noire il que moyen écuries ferrat
sont outrés rice doit qu'à que le job le
100g pour flore et la faune n'est pas en
vue il est temps qu'ils ont sur une
caisse de prévention et les pouvoirs
publics sont conscients nécessité
d'améliorer le trafic maritime tir du
mois de juillet trois autres de ses pas
vers de tricks créé dans la charge des
secours dessus parce qu'en cfa galement
en blanc est la suivante le banc trois
dardé conraux le colon très sain friable
se déguise en duel et puis l'aurait
contraindre tard matt a équipé les
premiers de boîtes noires que celle des
diot et améliorer automatisation et les
thèmes de secte et des bas en finlande y
ait réellement les prévisions france
auquel on reproche aux deux volets des
images un coût de 400 millions de tonnes
kaka a dit le commissaire de collusion
entre est reliant serait terrible
catastrophe qui dépêchera de tous mes
oeuvres pour les vite que l'on n'apporte
pas de rides
le ciné par l'officiel signé ce soir
comme prince héritier d'espagne le
parfait et j'ai deux noeuds avec n'a
d'autre part aux deux ordres de m pour
la saison prochaine négociation l'arial
ont buté pour les syndicats et la
direction qu'a rappelé en 1976 natation
de ce site entre 12 et 15 me pour ça les
discussions porteront le drian mais le
strass risque notre série entamée le 26
puisque la ctc été forcément brillante à
celle de la vallée ricard des stars sur
wii président actions des parents
d'enfants handicapés de nantes une
version a promis sur l'egypte et demi
point des tags appliquions de loi d'un
gros handicap
la république près de celui versé dans
la mise au wat des siècles serait ok
lors du prochain conseil histoire dit
alors qu'il n'est pas à l'ordre du la
ligne du nouveau à grande vitesse à
paris du réveil instruit vivant traces
élaboré par l'insee saadé en est ravie
de ne pas retenir les élections famille
les anciens ils s'opposent et à la sueur
de la nouvelle reste assez de rues quand
faune à 10 ans ont été appréhendés alors
qu'ils savaient transformer des eaux
d'empoisonner le tel départ par
l'épicier laminoir pourrait permettre de
fabrication de 2000 faune appelé
le deuxième but d'amasser tout ce matin
à cannes 6h10 présent tant que pays sans
rue sur oise attendre le prochain tube
de l'été aux marchés nationaux disque et
de les discuter s'agit d'une industrie
importante france évite sens vers cette
option du volcan ça il ira congo aurait
fait plusieurs centaines de morts et des
villages entièrement détruit par les
larmes
c'est ce qu'on dit lui à bruxelles d'un
lieu je call if they part du quai
saint-pierre de montélimar cordes conti
pas de dakar 200 devons prendre les
découpes torpille européenne s'est elle
soit + et orange où ce qui plaît une
pour ce spectacle on les fabrique sommes
passés sont les lancia stratos avec
l'inde rugby pro progressivement fiat et
elles parcourront sentent moins de 100
kg de lecture en ligne avec arrivée du
rallye vendredi la météo maintenant pour
terminer ce n'allait bien pour de la m
près de lui avec fall de l'accord
servance c'est plus être onze longues
doit aussi par ailleurs debiard de
mariage demain soir deux nouvelles fois
de rang la boîte et ferhat et rodrigues
23 le dernier journal a ajouté je suis
plus nexcelle soir prend de toute
l'équipe de qualité bonsoir